[Music]
gerado and mother car tester Manuel
Schaefer says it's only been two years
since Mazda launched they seat x3 now
they've already unveiled a revamp CX 3
for the 2017 model year few changes were
made to the outside but on the inside
the cx-3 boasts some new technological
improvements like GE vectoring control
it reduces engine torque while cornering
and shifts the load to the front wheels
that improves steering response and
makes for a more relaxing ride changes
were also made to the rear axle and
shock absorbers to improve passenger
comfort somewhat Amano says Mazda has
tweaked the cx-3 soundproofing too he
thinks you can really tell now you can
even drive the cx-3 at high speeds
without being bothered by car noise it's
a really pleasant ride absolute oniony
Mathiason the new CX 3 has an
eye-catching radiator grille with seven
horizontal slats chrome winglets extend
all the way to the cars headlights
higher-end trim levels include state of
the art extra bright and efficient LED
lights
[Music]
the vehicles rear looks both robust and
athletic as expected for a proper
crossover SUV
[Music]
it seeks that manual says the cx-3
Strunk has a capacity of 350 liters
not exactly a leader in the segment
you'll have even less space if you opt
for a Bose a sound system it'll deliver
great sound but it's subwoofer will
shrink your trunk space to 287 liters in
minor well thinks that's still enough
room for a big load of groceries
that's nice teaming of triangles and
iron coughs I what I get other side if
you fool down the rear seats you get an
almost level cargo floor the cx-3 also
provides smartphone connectivity an app
will open various social media
applications on the color display our
test car boasts the highest of the four
trim levels the sports line and comes
with a rear view camera and traffic sign
recognition and almost all CX 3 versions
cruise Matic cruise control a standard
smart city brake support is another
feature it can operate up to a speed of
80 kilometers an hour and recognizes
pedestrians
[Music]
the cx-3 can be had with two different
gasoline engines or diesel this test car
has front-wheel drive on a small
gasoline engine that puts out 88
kilowatts that accelerates from zero to
100 kilometers an hour in nine seconds
the cx-3 is also available as an
automatic and with four-wheel drive when
thought that amanda was verdict it's so
key that hardly any changes were made to
the 2017 CX 3 the cx-3 was a decent
vehicle from the get-go and just 2 years
old so it's understandable that Mazda
thought why change a winning formula
[Music]